okay I'm in town this week and of course
Nico and I got into another debate about
Cinema and whether or not things that
happen in movies can be done in real
life Nico's going on about Jason Bourne
one of the coolest action stars of all
time Nico says can't be taken too
seriously this is from the original
Bourne movie look at this off it goes so
cool right
that's a classic you can't actually be a
secret agent unless you can disappear on
the spot if you were to do that in real
life the person that's watching you
would be like oh you just ran with the
bus no they wouldn't you think he
realized like oh did he just magically
disappear it's right there
have you not actually stopped and looked
at this clip you can see his freaking
shoulder right now poking up look there
he is there's this reflection oh my God
that makes it so much cooler no he's
actually in the frame I thought they
edited that that's so much cooler
because now it's real obviously if you
saw him in it it may not be as cool but
the whole thing is you would use
misdirection and they wouldn't even be
looking for it they would be totally
shocked first of all just like they were
in the Batman piece but because you're
doing it on the street in broad daylight
it would be even more impressive what if
I come back into town next week well
they're still understanding the whole
shock of me being present I will
immediately disappear at the same time I
don't think that's possible but I will
help you and pull this off if Jason
Bourne would do it I think I got to do
it
right now there's a lot of unanswered
questions what is dreadstone who am I if
I'm gonna pull this off it's time I stop
asking and start telling
Pamela Landy it's me Jake and Bourne
first things first we gotta set the
stage okay okay
how do you want to do it nobody can know
that I'm in the studio so I'm gonna tell
them in the morning meeting that my
camera is not working now once
everyone's convinced that I'm not in the
studio I have formulated a plan where
Jonah's going to be filming a crew cuts
episode where he asks them what film
locations they remember about videos we
filmed on the streets I'll call Nico on
speakerphone while he's with them and
I'll ask to take a meeting Derek's gonna
get the van all set up where all I have
to do is jump in it at the right moment
Jonah will film The Mark and get their
reactions and Nick will be in a tent for
the long lens filming me As I Disappear
Jake and Bourne
thank you
Jake and born got almost everything I
need packed up for my trip I've got my
passports foreign currency I've even got
a dish towel that I'm going to use later
in a lethal manner but the most
important thing of all
are my besties courtesy of today's
sponsored Bessie now why does Jake and
Bourne wear vessies they're incredibly
versatile I can wear them in urban
environments in Forest environments I
can get on a plane I can get in a boat I
can go around with them I don't have to
think about what kind of shoes I have on
my feet based on what kind of
environment I am in but if that's not
enough the besties are 100 waterproof
meaning that I can wear them in mud rain
snow sleep flush anywhere and my socks
will be so dry I'll be in the dry sock
Club all day long they have two new
Styles the boardwalk which is their
breeziest easiest shoe yet and the storm
burst which is perfect for hiking and
more inclement conditions so if you're
interested in getting a pair of bessies
for yourself and being just like me head
on over to vesti.com Corridor crew or go
to vesti.com and use the promo code or
crew and you'll get 15 off your entire
order do whatever you got to do but just
remember this okay no matter where I am
watching
so no one nobody knows that I'm here
right now except for the few people that
are filming this video no one suspects a
thing the hardest part is always about
figuring out exactly how we're gonna do
it can we walk through this and get some
marks and figure out where exactly we're
going to be yeah there's a lot of
literal moving Parts here plus an actual
stunt that Jake's gonna have to pull off
so Jonah you're going to be going with
Nico to get each victim once the Mark is
in position Jake you'll call Nico I'll
be like hello and get them to turn
around turn around right now I'll start
kind of creeping I am everywhere but I
am nowhere remember that
all right things are coming together
nicely we like where things are at but
we need to do a few more tests let's see
how fast we can get the van jumps done
yeah and then we're good to go let's try
15. don't go any faster than that I am
everywhere but I am nowhere
guys that was really good the speed was
definitely better made it look more
boring but I think we need to get a
little bit faster
I am everywhere but I am nowhere
remember that
we get this shot it totally works
[Laughter]
okay who do you guys want to start with
I'm curious you know we're trying to
find the biggest fan of corridor that
works at Corridor okay and I figured
let's just walk down the iconic Street
to see you can name the most videos yeah
if you look around and uh portal trick
shots easy that one uh wizard freaking
wizard
[Music]
yeah man those two
am I dying out here Nico I need to talk
to Jordan Allen
do you know what's going on turn around
right now no you're not
just one of those freaking superheroes
but I am nowhere remember that
spear
[Applause]
Jesus Christ
what is this whole thing is set up for
freaking disappearing Jake
what is this he said he wasn't coming in
this week yeah he lied oh my gosh wow
Jake Jake and oh Jacob that was exciting
good I was just more thrilled to see you
that honestly was so surprising well
done
foreign
[Music]
Ted my Escape we're going to bring out
the crew one by one and see how many of
them we can fool
from Jake oh hey what's up Jake can you
speak to Sam hey what's up I'm here I'm
Jake's calling sorry one second Jake's
calling sorry one sec one sec hey Austin
yes hey are you at the studio right now
on the uh the side street okay perfect
because I just want you to know Matt
we're having this conversation face to
face
turn around
face to face he's behind you
[Music]
what are you doing here yeah
what
just know this I'll be watching here
that's ominous
no way
no way that was so cool he actually just
what
what that one really that one worked
really well so before we end this
conversation know this I was never here
[Music]
oh
come on what
[Laughter]
no only one thing I am everywhere and I
am nowhere at all
Austin
[Music]
I was never here
okay all right
now the possible places that he could
have gone over the course of that van
passing by I feel are pretty limited I
will always be there
and then the car drives and then he
disappears
see I caught that part
whoa that's slick I like it I like it
wow know this I am everywhere but I am
nowhere everywhere and nowhere what is
he talking about
wait
[Music]
what the
wait what
uh
all right uh what the heck wait is he
what is Project black one
Hey Jake
dude that was incredible I am blown away
I looked over and it's like you're
standing there like freaking Jason
Bourne I'm like oh and then the van goes
by as perfectly as you said the light
and you are gone you weren't gone I was
like I was watching a movie but it was
in real life I feel special to have
witnessed that that was I'm honestly
legitimately kind of mind blown right
now that was awesome for me I've never
no one's ever disappeared in front of me
before
um except for my father at a young age I
do feel like he's just behind that car
though or is he in the van okay he
jumped into the side that makes sense
he got me he was there and then he
wasn't I don't know how to process that
usually people are there and then they
stay there so I'm in another Jake prank
video right now yeah yeah you are all
right well that was filmed on this
street